You've heard about the War on Drugs for years, right?
It's always been framed as a campaign to keep us safe.
But what if that was never the real story?
What if the whole thing was actually built on a political calculation?
Well, we're gonna dive deep into that.
And it all starts with one absolutely jaw-dropping quote.
Yeah, you heard that right.
That is a direct quote, an on-the-record admission from a key figure,
someone who was right there in the inner circle when the Modern War on Drugs was launched.
A statement like that, it just reframes everything, doesn't it?
So the big question is, who on earth would say something like that?
And why?
Okay, so to really get how big of a deal this confession is, you have to know who said it.
And let me tell you, this wasn't some low-level staffer or an intern, nope.
This came straight from the top.
The man's name was John Ehrlichman,
and he was President Richard Nixon's chief of domestic policy.
I mean, think about that role for a second.
This guy was one of the most powerful people in the White House.
He was an architect of their entire domestic agenda.
That means he had a front-row seat to the real conversations,
the ones that happened behind closed doors, far away from any cameras or reporters.
So his words aren't just speculation,
they're an eyewitness account from inside the room where it all happened.
So here it is, the full strategy straight from Ehrlichman himself.
He said the Nixon campaign had two enemies.
The anti-war left and black people.
Now, obviously, you can't just make it illegal to protest a war,
and you certainly can't make it illegal to be black.
So what did they do?
They found a workaround.
They worked to get the public to associate hippies with marijuana
and black communities with heroin.
Then you pass laws that heavily criminalize both of those drugs.
And just like that, you have a perfectly legal tool to disrupt those communities.
You can arrest their leaders, raid their homes,
and in his words, vilify them night after night on the evening news.
The key takeaway here is just, wow, it was never really about the drugs.
The drugs were the weapon.
What Ehrlichman described is a very specific and pretty cynical tactic,
but it's actually just one example of a much broader political playbook.
It's a playbook based on shifting your language to achieve the same goals
when the old ways of speaking become, well, socially unacceptable.
And get a load of this.
This is another one of those incredibly candid quotes,
this time from the famous Republican strategist, Lee Atwater.
He's explaining the mechanics of what became known as the Southern Strategy.
And what's wild is that he's not even defending it.
He's dissecting it like a mechanic taking apart an engine.
He's saying that as society changed and overt racism became political poison,
the messaging had to evolve.
It had to become more abstract.
And this slide just illustrates that evolution perfectly.
Atwater breaks it down into clear steps.
You start with the explicit, ugly stuff.
When that stops working for you politically, you pivot.
You move to coded policy terms like states' rights or forced busing,
things that were widely understood at the time to be about race
without explicitly saying so.
And then it gets even more abstract.
You start talking in purely economic terms, like cutting taxes,
which, as Atwater himself noted, could still have a racially disparate impact.
The language gets more and more indirect,
but the intended effect can stay exactly the same.
There's a political term for this tactic.
It's called a dog whistle.
And the analogy is perfect, right?
A real dog whistle makes a sound only dogs can hear.
Well, a political dog whistle is language designed to sound harmless
to the general population, but to send a very different,
very specific message to a targeted subgroup of voters.
It's the core mechanism behind that abstract attack.
Now, you might be thinking,
okay, this is some pretty intense stuff from the 1960s.
You know, a product of that specific turbulent time.
But the truth is, this playbook of linking drugs to minority groups
to justify a policy, yeah, that was an old trick
even before Nixon got to the White House.
Let's wind the clock all the way back to the 1930s.
The very first person in charge of the nation's Federal Drug Enforcement Agency
was a man named Harry J. Anslinger.
And the rhetoric he used to push for the criminalization of marijuana,
well, it's set a precedent that would echo for decades to come.
I mean, just listen to Anslinger's own words here.
He's not talking about public health data or medical research.
He is explicitly tying marijuana to race,
Negroes, Hispanics, Filipinos, and to culture
that he clearly disapproved of, calling jazz music satanic.
This wasn't a subtle dog whistle.
This was a bullhorn.
It shows that from the very, very beginning,
American drug policy was all tangled up
with racial and cultural anxieties.
So we've seen the political strategy
and we've seen its historical roots.
But this was never just an abstract game of words and policies.
This war had real devastating consequences,
measured in millions of human lives.
Let's just look at the numbers.
This timeline is, honestly, it's staggering.
When Nixon declared his war on drugs in 1971,
the entire U.S. prison population was around 300,000.
Then Reagan expanded the war.
Then Clinton signed the big tough-on-crime bill in 94.
And look at where we are today.
2.3 million people behind bars.
The policies put in place had a direct, dramatic,
and truly explosive effect on incarceration in this country.
And let's just focus on that number for a second.
Since 1980, the number of people in prison or jail,
specifically for a drug offense,
has increased by 1,100%.
Not 100, 1100%.
That's not a gradual shift.
That is a seismic explosion in one single category of crime.
So who did this explosion affect the most?
This chart tells a pretty clear story.
Black Americans make up about 13% of the U.S. population,
but they account for 38% of all drug arrests
and an absolutely unbelievable 59% of those
in state prison for drug offenses.
And here's the thing.
Research consistently shows that white people
and black people use drugs at very similar rates.
So the disparity isn't about who's using.
It's about who's being punished.
And nothing illustrates this disparity more clearly
than the infamous laws around crack versus powder cocaine.
Pharmacologically, they're the same drug.
But crack, which was associated with poor black communities,
got you a mandatory five-year prison sentence
for just five grams.
Powder cocaine, associated with more affluent white users,
required 500 grams.
That's 100 times the amount
to trigger that exact same sentence.
The result, 93% of those convicted for crack offenses were black.
Just let that sink in for a moment.
This comparison provides some really crucial global context.
It's a shocking statistic that forces us to grapple
with the sheer scale and the racial disparity
of mass incarceration in the United States.
So how did this all happen in an era
that claimed to be moving past over discrimination?
Well, it all comes back to where we started.
The power of language and the incredible success
of that abstract attack.
And this is really the final piece of the puzzle.
The whole political conversation shifted.
Instead of arguing about segregation,
which was no longer acceptable,
politicians started arguing about crime.
This allowed racially biased outcomes to continue,
not through explicitly racist laws,
but through a new system of so-called colorblind law enforcement
that was, in practice, anything but.
So what's the big takeaway from all this?
I think it's about the importance of developing
what some people call critical consciousness.
It's just the process of becoming aware
of how these huge social and political systems actually work,
seeing the connections between language, policy,
and their real-world impact.
Because understanding why something happened
is always the first step toward figuring out how to change it.
And that brings us to our final thought.
This playbook, identifying a political enemy,
linking them to a perceived threat,
and using abstract, coded language
to mobilize public opinion against them,
is not a relic of history.
It didn't just disappear.
So the crucial question we're left with is this.
Now that you know the playbook,
now that you can recognize the pattern,
where else do you see it playing out
in the world around you right now?